some people are so agitated the monkey
mind they've got too many things going
on and they're thinking okay they're
trying to sit down and write i suffer
from this and i'm feeling like wait i've
also got this person i need to connect
with and i'm kind of being drawn off
course by not being able to put the
blinders on for people that have that
issue i think
learning how to calm the nervous system
is very powerful and the best way that i
know how to do that is based on two
studies one published in nature one
publishing cell reports recently showing
that physiological size are one of the
fastest ways to bring our overall level
of autonomic arousal down and a
physiological sigh is a two inhales
followed by an extended exhale so it's
like
it's not just a deep breath it's two
inhales followed by an exhale what that
does and this has been shown several
times now in humans and other species as
well as it dilates the little sacs of
the lungs and that second inhale dilates
them a little bit more and it pulls a
little bit of carbon dioxide out of the
bloodstream so that when we exhale we
offload the maximum amount of carbon
dioxide and it perfectly adjusts the
ratio of carbon dioxide and oxygen in
the bloodstream and lungs and sometimes
it only takes one of these double inhale
exhales sometimes somebody needs to do
two or three but that's the fastest way
to bring the autonomic nervous system
down
the other thing is we talk a lot about
sleep and sleep is extremely important
but there are other modes of and brain
states that can allow you to recover one
of the ones that i'm a huge proponent of
and that my lab has been studying in
other labs or studying is what many
people call yoga nidra it's a wonderful
practice you know just lying down and
focusing enough of your attention so
that you don't fall asleep and enough of
your attentions on and moving it around
so that you're not really concentrating
on any one thing hypnosis is very
similar deep relaxation
wandering sort of attention
fairly narrow context
but
it brings the brain into these unique
states where you're neither asleep nor
awake and for people that have trouble
falling asleep or trouble relaxing
themselves these kinds of practices are
extremely useful because they're really
teaching you how to turn off those modes
of focus so you know we live in a stress
society some people are stressed because
they're overwhelmed but other people are
stressed because they just don't know
how to turn off their brain and fall
asleep and so if you want to learn how
to turn off your brain and fall asleep
these practices are immensely useful
we're now looking at how daily breathing
exercises can impact people's sleep and
levels of stress he's done a lot of work
on addiction and trauma and pain
management through hypnosis and most all
of hypnosis that's clinical involves
bringing one's state into one of deeper
relaxation not full sleep
and then thinking about some behavioral
change that one wants to make these are
ancient practices really and i think
that they were developed by people that
understood
that rewiring of the brain requires
focus and deep rest what's interesting
about hypnosis is it brings those two
things together at the same moment so
normally you'll work really hard on
something work really hard then you'll
sleep and that's when the plasticity
occurs but hypnosis likely accelerates
that whole process by
having people enter a state of deep
relaxation and focus at the same time
and allows those circuits to reshape
themselves and there's some published
data from david's lab to support that
that's fascinating so i think these
practices are really useful some people
have a hard time turning off their
thoughts it's really hard remember you
can't do it what you can do is to learn
to control that perceptual window and
distribute it so that your sense of time
starts to kind of drift off and you end
up in sleep more easily and it's a
practice that most people find if they
do it for 10 minutes a day or so they
start sleeping much better within within
a week or sometimes more they sometimes
people need some other help like not
drinking caffeine late in the day etc
but
that brain state of
no duration path and outcome analysis is
going to be the most restorative and you
can get it in wakefulness too so taking
a walk where you're just letting your
mind go
is very powerful and the other thing
that's powerful is optic flow so
self-generated optic flow by walking
running or cycling shifts the brain into
a state of relaxation that's not seen
when you're stationary this is well
described in the neuroscience literature
for some reason it's not well described
in the wellness literature
but it's a real thing when you move
through space
you're active there's a natural calming
of the brain circuits involved in threat
and threat detection this is the basis
for emdr eye movement desensitization
reprocessing
the lateralized eye movements they have
people do in the clinic that kind of
goofy looking thing while they're there
talk about that to overcome fear and
trauma that lowers stress and the the
the rationale is that by coupling a low
stress state to the recall of the trauma
it's gonna allow people to reshape their
relationship to the trauma to tolerate
the discomfort